- As petrol and diesel get phased out
and batteries become better and cheaper,
electric trucks are slowly
starting to become a thing.
But the trouble is you need a
massive battery in each truck,
plus the infrastructure
to charge them all.
It'd be great if you could
somehow charge up electric trucks
while they're on the move.
Well, the world already has
a proven, tested solution
for sending power to massive,
fast-moving vehicles.
Electric trains have pulled
power from overhead wires
for more than a century.
So why not put those wires over
the first lane of a highway
and let trucks connect to it
while they're on the move?
- So it's been running for 21 months now
and will be at least for the next year.
The full-scale scenario for Germany
would be to equip 1/3 of
the German highway network
and that could reduce
2/3 of the greenhouse gas
emissions by heavy trucks.
But for sure, there are pros
and cons in the real world,
and we want to be sure
before we are going into the
future with such a system.
There were a lot of safety
concerns in the beginning,
so we had to discuss everything
with fire brigade and police and so on.
We have the voltage level of a tram
and the electromagnetic fields
are lower than on a tram,
so that isn't an issue.
Overtaking is absolutely no problem!
You just set the indicator
or leave the lane
and the pantograph will
automatically drop down immediately
and they are free to go.
So in that part,
a battery or the combustion
engine will take over,
and you will have the full
power without interruption.
- One of the things that's
really obvious sitting here
is that the technology works.
Like, we're running off grid power now
and it's really, really quiet in here.
There are two main uses
for big trucks like this.
One is last mile delivery,
picking up lots of items from warehouses
and taking them out to individual shops.
Most of that is going to be away
from the trunk road network,
so eHighway wouldn't work for that,
but those trucks tend to
take shorter journeys anyway,
and they're sitting idle at night.
So those could charge at the depot.
The other use for big trucks
is taking containers
from ports to warehouses,
or from one depot to another.
Almost all of that traffic
goes along big trunk roads like this,
and that could all be converted
to run straight from the grid
with batteries taking a
couple of miles at each end.
Roll that out,
and suddenly you're
replacing a lot of diesel.
- What you're doing is
bringing the electrons to
the vehicle in a cable,
rather than trying to carry
them in a box in a battery.
It's the most efficient solution,
the most efficient use of energy.
We think that it's possible
for the system to pay for itself.
It's possible to set an electricity price
sufficiently cheap for the truck operator
that the lower costs will pay for
the additional costs of the lorry
in about a year and a half,
something like that.
And we think that it's possible to use
some of the money that comes
back from electricity sales
to pay the infrastructure provider
in a way which will make that
an investment that's
fundable by private finance.
And we think there is enough
money left on top of that
to pay a tax to the government
to replace fuel tax.
Where you've got real difficulties
is some of these journeys
into really remote parts of the country.
And there's a strong
case for saying, look,
in some of those journeys,
let's have a hybrid vehicle.
But the majority of the
system works very well
on very efficient electricity,
and you can do it quickly.
So I think that's an attractive
thing to do if you can.
- We've had more than a century
to develop delivery infrastructure
that's based around
combusting fossil fuels,
and that's going to end in
the next couple of decades.
Britain is planning to ban
the sale of new petrol
and diesel trucks by 2040,
which sounds like the far future,
but it's actually only 18 years away.
The rest of Europe won't be far behind
and building those
wires above enough roads
could take up most of that time,
if that's the solution that's chosen.
So right now we know the
basic technology does work.
That's what's been tested here,
but a lot of things that technically work
can't be built economically.
If we want to keep to that date,
then the UK has somewhere
around three to five years
to figure out if this is just a gimmick
or whether it's worth
investing the billions
that it'll take to roll this out.
Personally, I try not to give
predictions about the future,
but I wouldn't be too surprised
if those wires become part
of everyday life on the road
in the next couple of decades.